hello hear me uh so-so okay thanks uh my
name is Tudor and welcome to the best
joint talk at by dated Chicago yes the
best and only joint talk at PI data
Chicago um so tutor and i work at shift
key and we're going to talk a little bit
about our experience production eliza ng
our first data science model extra-thick
um this was the first time the data
science teens the engineering teens had
worked together and we ran out some
issues along the way and came up with
some best practices and we'd like to
share them with you so I introduce
myself I am stuck in a software engineer
at ship pic for about two years I start
off as a JavaScript engineer and moved
on to python about a year ago and I
should say that I am NOT a data
scientist and clearly I'm not a software
engineer i joined shift gig about a year
ago as the first full-time data
scientists and my background is in
physics and computational neuroscience
um since i was the first data scientist
at shift gig this meant i had a lot of
opportunities to work really closely
with the engineering team because
they're pretty much my only peers and
they had to give me access to all the
databases now too i'll tell you a little
bit about cheating it's just a quick
overview um the main part of that ship
to golfers is a visual marketplace that
connects businesses with already workers
so we provide fully vetted workers that
we call specialists this mobile app that
allows them to claim shifts based on
their skill preferences and their
schedule and on the business side for
our clients we offer tools to help two
of them manage their event rosters
submit timecards and rating favorite
specialists that like to see again well
um now I'm going to tell you a little
bit about this project that were worked
on which was a reliability score for our
specialists so we created this score as
a way to quantify the reliability of a
specialist based on their history with
us
there are two main features one is a
retention component do they stay on the
shifts that they claim and a completion
component do they actually work the
ships that they claim currently it's
visible to the specialist and the
specialist appt with this gauge that you
can see goes from not good to excellent
and the gauge changes daily depending on
if their score has changed um we're not
showing it to clients yet we're still
doing some experiments on how effective
it is um hopefully it's doing something
uh and we think this is something that
can distinguish us from traditional
staffing agencies traditional temporary
staff agencies are still run with like
phones and writing things down so sensor
a tech company we have a lot of data and
we think we can leverage that to produce
a smarter marketplace so I'll tell you a
little bit about how we develop the
score so initially when we started this
project the data science team what's
working on it um so we used our
intuition to develop the first
components we've done a few studies on
correlations and different parts of
their work history so we know that
there's a correlation between dropping
shifts in the app and not showing up to
your shifts so we knew we wanted this to
be a factor in the liability so I came
up with a few components and developed a
few different formulas to test against
and the main way I tested these
different versions was by checking the
score distribution for all of our
workers and looking at a lot of summary
statistics at the mean standard
deviation um we knew we didn't want to
score where everyone was failing because
he thought that would be really
depressing for the specialist um we also
didn't want a score where everyone was
doing really well um because we wanted
them to have something to strive towards
us we wanted a distribution that was
sort of well balanced where you know if
you really were a good worker you'd have
a good score if you're sort of in the
middle you had something to work towards
and if you're bad hopefully you'll get
fired um so I because there are a few
different components I was able to test
different weights for the different
components and different time scales um
so after looking at the distributions
and talking with other stakeholders and
think
about the business considerations we
chose um and what we consider it to be
an optimal time scale and waits for the
different features at the same time
though I knew these were likely to need
to be changed in the future so I wanted
to make sure the software engineers left
us flexibility to change these things
once the score was in production okay so
then we had a handoff unfortunately
there was no ice cream um so I gave the
backend engineers a Jupiter notebook
with my sequel queries and my code for
all the formulas to me it was very clear
what I was giving them it's like just
query the database for these exact
things that I've given you use these
weights these are the components I've
decided on shouldn't be any controversy
just implement them um and also but
leave me the flexibility to change these
in the future while we're on the slide
please enjoy the off-brand minions that
we have up there that we found that
could use for free so so at this point
myself and a few other software
engineers came onto the project we got
an idea of what the requirements were
and we got the stupid notebooks we had
no idea what to print objects were and
never seen this before and so we
realized we kind of had to we had these
these components we got to implement but
we also had to think of kind of an aura
arching architecture for how the score
framework is going to work how can
production lies it how's me made
available to the specialists if I'm
going to persist in and so on so yeah we
just thought we set our stories and our
job process and then kind of the food
was engineers your started hacking at
this so our team came up with a couple
of requirements that we had to we have
to deal with first of all we have to
make sure the specialist could see that
the third score so happy part of our
part of a viewable vr api we wanted to
persist the score history because we
wanted data scientists to be able to
take a look at
transverse of a specific specialist all
they've been doing over time and kind of
take a look at that the policy fusion of
scores has changed with time we want to
have a really scalable implementation so
because we're a growing company we can
have more specialists so we want to make
sure that we can handle a giant copying
this course for giant hold of
specialists we also wanted to flexible
architecture where as the score grows in
complexity as now we only had two
features we'd be able to change
implementation of features and add more
and more as we go and finally well this
is going to be a service that creates
that's calculates and persistence core
in production in the dev environment
could also be used as it will as a way
for the data science team to kind of
play around with the score and try
different score distributions add
features and so on so it's a little bit
of thinking and we thought we came up
with a pretty good solution uh and we
depended we went to one of our favorite
tools that we use a shift game celery
how many of you guys have heard of
celery Python celery hopefully all of
your part of celery oh so celery that's
a isn't going to ask you that we use
whenever we want to have a particular
set of functionality that's executed in
the third way or at a particular or
schedule for a particular time so one of
the ways we use it one examples I have
whether users are shifting is when a
specialist my climate shift will have a
celery task where I'm 24 hour in 24
hours we'll set such that will email
them a notification that hey you know
your your ship is coming up make sure
you show up yeah uniform and all that so
that's all the ways that we use it but
here what's really nice about Saturday's
first of all is that it has it handles
multi-processing so we can repair eliza
workflow which help
us with large amount of worker special
still going to have to deal with and not
the cool thing about medical
functionality of etc is celery cords
sawed away chords allows you to link
together what am I call like child
subtasks such that when they're executed
and execute in parallel once all of them
are finished and there is also a
variable these results be sent to a
parent task that would execute something
so it's kind of a function that has
multiple multiple inputs and with that
it might do something else I might
return the output based on stat and that
seems to fit a sort of something I want
to do for like a weight weight average
where we have multiple kinds of multiple
image that come in and we want to
compute something in the parent task and
I have a thought I thought I thought
like were kind of made sense as a
musical chord as well so I have a goal
cord in there you know many many notes
together something greater comes out of
it not sure if that's what they were
thinking uh considering with the musical
kind of thinking here we we say I'm a
final solution for software we called it
a bolero have many of you heard others
bulova una with it piece of classical
music maybe so it's something that kind
of starts off in the stately manner with
only a few instruments and it kind of
builds up and adds more instruments and
becomes more complex so that seemed to
both mesh with the fact that were
starting off with very few features I'm
going to build up more in the future but
also kind of help it was a good way the
good analogy for the way that these
chords work and kind of fan out in fat
and thumb back in and kind of growing
complexity so we had a so um we would
have these these baby bath shops where
we would get all of our specialists and
create a giant cord for all of our
specialists and within these these
within this cord we'd have tasks that
would start off chords for calculating
the score and each in the chords we made
up of the various components
it's that Nicole had sent us so and what
this allows to do was basically was
abstract our differences in within the
components such that at the end of every
cycle at the end of every task execution
we'd be persisting the particular
component value the two database as well
as a score the final score value so that
meant that any time if you want to look
at the specialist score history I didn't
particular time be able to see the
breakdown at a very granular level of
what their score looked like at each of
these features so um uh and so this
dealt with our persistent our
persistence requirement with our
scalability a problem and as and the
flexibility is there in the fact that
you can add as many cap as many tasks in
the cord as you like we can simply add
component 345 build that out and it will
return and calculate the final score
that way the final piece was mixed it's
very configurable for data science and
that's where we came up that's where we
made use of llamo configuration file
that completely mirrored the celery
workflow that we had created sure some
of you have heard of yambol as some of
you know what it stands for yes also
they used to stand for yamo a markup
language another sense for now yeah I'm
gonna get those confused so what we did
is that we the entire score workflow is
based off of a yamo config file so what
this means is that without having to
change any Python code then a science
team go in and basically change the
weights of the configuration of any
component add and remove components and
be able to i do it very very quickly on
the score implementation we love having
to submit like this no requests or to
have to go through a more complicated
process of that it's now very very very
configurable a
now that we got your picture in mind it
was time to actually implement ourselves
the features that the coop provided us
so and keep in mind that what we were
given was Jupiter notebooks from from
data science team and we had work of
Jupiter notice before so our first
impression was that this is very this
isn't this is their kind of experimental
code this is so that they were trying
out and it's kind of like a template or
a rubric that we can base our artwork
off of which is definitely not what the
designs was thinking so we're going
through all the queries that we see in
supernova called the implementation at
some point we say well no one of these
features the implementation is kind of
unfair we don't think you know we're
soccer engineers and we have some I
we've been company for a while so we
have some idea of what the business
logic is like and we think I feels like
we should really change this somehow and
make fits and you know have a little
tiny tweak to the to the way this is
implemented so the software engineers
and I would going through a slack room
we talked about it and we're like okay
yeah we're gonna go change it and with
the handoff mentality we didn't really
communicate this the data science team
at all so yeah that was so trouble was
brewing or conflict uh yeah so they made
all these changes didn't tell me but at
some point I got curious and checked the
valero codebase that's when I discovered
these changes and they were for my point
of view very significant changes in the
components so we made the great decision
to talk about this on slack instead of
in person we all sit within 15 feet of
each other so we can all sit each other
uh we can see each other I don't know if
you guys have ever had intense
conversations on slack I just call it
like we rage typing and then you get up
and go to the bathroom and like you have
to not make eye contact with a person
you're conversing with it's really
difficult um so in our slack channel for
bolero
I message a few the software engineers
and was like what's going on like you
guys changed all this up it feels like
it what happened behind the data science
teams back like what is happening um so
got kind of intense um from my point of
view felt like the engineers were upset
that we had specific specifications for
the features and that didn't really make
sense to me at all I wasn't sure why
they would be upset about that from our
point of view um I we definitely
realized we we should have communicated
some things but at the same time you
felt like you know we we have some
interest then we have some knowledge of
the business logic and we thought you
know we wanted to make sure that our
opinions were hurt as well on and we
would have a discussion basically on
this and we kind of felt like data
science wasn't really hearing us out on
what we thought was the best way forward
with this particular feature yeah so I
went home that day and I was super upset
I felt like my work wasn't being
respected why did she get even higher
data scientist like if they're not gonna
use my work um and when I went home I
also reran the score with the changes
the engineers and made and shockingly it
changed the distribution um the main
change was that although they thought
they were making the score more fair
they actually ended up lowering the
average score for all the workers which
was not something that the data science
team wanted yeah and we didn't have the
kind of thing once knowledge to
understand what what the effect would be
uh so yeah very kind of sheepish
reaction to that so the next day we set
up a meeting where we talked in person
instead of an slack um so as me tie the
head of back-end engineering um where's
talking to unlock the day before my boss
who's the head of data science the vp of
product in the vp of engineering so um
my boss and the VPS were kind of like
what the hell was happening yesterday
like were you guys doing um so we all
kind of agree that we should have
switched to talking in person earlier
tone is really hard to figure out in
typing um so I reported back
the changes they had made had
dramatically changed the score
distributions for all the workers and
actually brought the mean score down um
I explained all of the research that I
got into our choices for the weights and
the different components and stuff um
and ty explained that he actually hadn't
been angry on slack um it just sort of
felt like he was angry and he has a
serious face um just hard to tell yeah
um and that engineering wasn't trying to
undermine us um I think they just they
didn't have a sense of all the work that
had gone into our choices and as tutor
mentioned they sort of viewed gboro
notebooks as a template more than
something that was set in stone um so we
agreed that data science and engineering
would go over the code together before
anything was released to production to
make sure that everyone was on the same
page and one of the things we wanted to
make sure was that there was this so
division between data science and
software engineering where one group was
a thinker and one group was the doer we
wanted to be able to be part of the
conversation and that's the kind of
thinking that we went forward that we
went forward with went about buying the
rest of the project in our stories we
made sure to include some sort of data
science or recite into into into our
implementation we had these clips sort
of regular check in reviews we kind of
had a run-through of the entire code
base with with Nicole and we're very
excited to see how interested she was
basically and what we were thinking of
doing and had a lot of really good ideas
that were that contributed a lot and
this kind of all came together where we
were about to production lies this
application and we had to go through we
have to do some thinking on functional
testing load testing and we wanted to
make sure that we had everything that
the final version of our code was
exactly what the signs expected and uh
yeah so Nicole provided us with some
data prior to the release i gave them a
test worker set based off of my own code
for them to test against so that we
would know for sure
that what i thought the components were
matched with what what they had
implemented and after that meeting we
all collaborated a lot more closely on
the implementation um there were times
when I was trapped in a room with
multiple engineers trying to write
sequel queries it was very smelly and
horrible um we were there for like three
hours working on one query and we
couldn't even get lunch um so
collaboration and yeah for my part when
I finally got the entire workflow
running I made sure to save the sort of
the snapshot of a database that they
called it go through make sure
distribution matches where she expected
and to kind of check over her her you
see a specific specialist that she had
the test worker said she had set up for
us and for that we well yeah we got it
working we're scoring specialists
they're seeing the score yeah so yeah so
now we have a few takeaways um the first
one is absolutely slack is really
horrible for intense conversations um as
I said earlier tone is very difficult to
assess in writing we should have
switched a talking in person as soon as
things not more complicated or when
somebody was confused instead of just
you know barreling through this slack
conversation um because we were a
start-up we have really limited
conference face so I think the lack of
meeting rooms may have also contributed
to this we were just or like well
there's nowhere for us to go but I think
even if we had just gone and walked
around the block together that would
have been better than trying to write
things and sort of everyone being really
confused about what everyone's
intentions were okay take away to
document everything um I assume that the
engineers only needed to see the final
version of my score formula I didn't
think they would necessarily be
interested in all the work that had gone
into choosing the different weights um
which is definitely a mistake on my part
um I don't really know I thought that
obviously they know how to thank their
creative people um not you
um so I learned that the engineers
wanted to be involved in the data
science project and they obviously had
valuable contributions to make based on
their prior knowledge and their superior
Python skills um so definitely I think
if I had documented things and sort of
shared things more along the way um we
would have skipped some of these issues
that we ran into the other side of this
equation sort of the complement is to
issue documentation is to ask lots of
questions if there isn't anything
documented we didn't have a good idea of
why decisions for me it would be really
easy to to basically get an idea of what
the thought process was like for each
feature we're going to implement and
because of the handoff mentality that we
had we just kind of assumed were working
in a silo and data science had their own
sort of priorities at this point so
we're kind of left on our own to deal
with this tutors that's right next to me
so we just had to turn his head 90
degrees a fourth take away which is
something that we we've been working
more towards at shift get guests and Bob
stakeholders throughout the span of the
project that assigns put a lot of work
into the reliability score that a skill
set a knowledge base that was absent on
software engineering team and we were
ill-prepared to understand some the
nuance in search the data to the beta
team made so we really benefited from
having that know how even it's just it
just kind of as a resource there in our
scrum meetings tavi designs there was
something that was essential to getting
the the project running in the end yeah
this is something we've really taken to
heart at shift gig um data science and
engineering are obviously relatively
close in the grand scheme of our company
we sit in the same space or on the same
slap channels but we do a lot of work
with other departments like accounting
and sales and marketing so we found that
our projects throw a lot more smoothly
if we have representatives from those
departments
coming in and working with us during all
the whole length of the projects I'm
having someone come to the scrums every
day and come to the planning so that
everyone knows what's going to be
delivered you know what the problems are
so less of this handoff mentality that
just leads to lots of confusion at the
end it's on the more positive takeaways
that we can build something amazing
together software engineering data
science side by side we both have
complementary skill sets and we were
really well when we combine our domain
knowledge asst yeah um working together
we can leverage all the creative
thinking there everyone's capable of a
shift gig like everyone knows how to
problem-solve and it's better if we work
together instead of creating problems
for each other to solve we have plenty
outside problems to figure out oh wait
um so that was our talk we want to thank
all of our co-workers at shift gig um
they had to listen to our practice talks
they had to actually work with us um
thanks to our bosses for letting us
present they wanted us to say that ship
gig is hiring both data scientists and
software engineers so send them an email
or talk to one of us after the talk
thanks the idea for thank you all for
coming here we'd appreciate it
and we thank each other
the question was how we document data
science projects now um wait effing use
docstrings and comment my code which I
wasn't doing before um but also I've
been writing reports for the internal
data science team which sort of
explained all the experiments I had done
and like made graphs like the different
weights and stuff like that but I didn't
give any of that to engineering so after
that I was a lot more thoughtful about
sharing that stuff and also writing
documents um in such a way that people
without data science knowledge could
sort of understand what's happening or
at least have references of things to
look up we use Google Docs it's a pain
in the ass
okay so the question is we used to have
a handoff process and we try to change
it something new and how do we handle
making sure that we collaborate without
having wall-to-wall meetings and crazy
schedules or everyone's calendar is
blocked off because they're someone
else's teams meetings so I think so
we've gone through we've shifted to more
of a two different kind of scrum team
set up where we will have a
representative a different team kind of
there for just the five minutes chrome
that we have on this particular process
and that's usually the length of their
involvement on theta beta day and that's
where we'll pick up any questions that
we have of course is always slack to to
send off one of requests which of course
rather do in person then dense lock we
learned something so and what we have we
have a sort of bi weekly planning
meetings that work that sir domain
specific individuals who work on a
project will take part it and so the
extent of the time that's spent is
basically a one hour or one hour and a
half a week or so yeah I would also say
I think our mentalities more invite
everyone and then people can self-select
out if they don't need to be at a
meeting and that's a better outcome then
if people are left out of meetings um
and also to not go into private select
channels to talk about our brothers